Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es ist Zeit für die Ligatour. Wir blicken auf die Männer-Ligen in Frankreich, in Italien, Spanien und England. Jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 260. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zur Ligatour. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und ich freue mich sehr, heute wieder die Legendenrunde hier zu begrüßen. Zum einen Marius Seuke von Serie Amore unter anderem. Hallo Marius.
Grüß dich.
Dann ist Fabian Pacolat hier. Fabian, hallo, schön, dass du hier bist. Genau, man kann dir als Ed Rosengartler folgen. Und außerdem wieder hier vom Kicker. Ich freue mich sehr. Michael Postel. Hallo Michi.
Max, grüß dich. Dankeschön.
Und glaubst du, das bringt Villareal jetzt noch ins Ziel, dass man eben da auf Rang 5 oder 6 bleiben kann?
Also es ist wirklich schwierig. Also ich glaube nicht mehr, dass Brighton das packt, obwohl die mir grundsätzlich am besten gefallen. Aber das ist ein qualitatives Problem, glaube ich, bei denen, dass sie es einfach vom Spielermaterial her nicht haben. Tottenham ist bodenlos. Deswegen glaube ich eigentlich auch fast, dass die das gar nicht packen.
Ach so, dann wäre es ja schon erreicht.
Genau, und dann hast du es eigentlich schon. Und wahrscheinlich reicht ja Platz 7 auch.
Stimmt.
Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen, dass es reicht.
Richtig, den Rang 7, den habe ich jetzt gar nicht mit reingerechnet. Also das sieht da dann wirklich sehr gut aus für Aston Villa. Dann habe ich nur noch eine abschließende Frage an dich, Uli. Und zwar, welche Spiele müssen wir uns unbedingt angucken? Eins, das hast du jetzt schon genannt, das findet jetzt auch erst am heutigen Abend statt. Also wir nehmen am Donnerstag den 27. April auf. Wenn ihr schnell seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann könnte euch die Spurs gegen United noch geben. Was gibt es denn darüber hinaus noch zu gucken?
Also es geht schon weiter Samstag, Sonntag und dann auch Montag. Ich glaube trotzdem, dass man Tottenham im Auge behalten muss, weil das ist so das Finale dann am Sonntag gegen Liverpool, bei Liverpool hast du ja schon mal kurz angesprochen. Ich glaube, das muss man gucken. Und worauf ich mich tatsächlich sehr freue ist, auch weil es so ein kleines Abstiegs-Endspiel auch ist. Ich glaube nämlich, dass das Team, das es gewinnt, durch ist. Crystal Palace am Samstag zur frühen Anschlusszeit gegen West Ham United. West Ham fehlt glaube ich noch ein Punkt oder ein Sieg. Das traue ich ihnen zu. Dann sind die durch. Und bei Crystal Palace soll es eigentlich schon reichen. Wenn sie es aber packen, dann sind auch die durch. Das sind gerade die Duellen, die vom Matchplanning her dankenswerterweise immer genauso hingehen, dass ganz oft solche Spiele sind, wo man dann weiß, ah okay, die sind raus, die kann ich abhaken. Das gefällt mir gerade ganz gut in der Premier League. Das ist natürlich Zufall, aber es ist schön, wie es fällt gerade.
Sehr, sehr gut. Also es geht langsam auf die entscheidende Phase zu. Auch hier in dieser Ligatur, bzw. hier ist dann die entscheidende Phase eigentlich schon vorbei, wenn man ehrlich ist. Denn jetzt möchte ich mich von dir verabschieden. Uli, du hast dich hier trotz gesundheitlich angeschlagener Stimme durchgepeitscht. Vielen, vielen Dank dir für deine Zeit. Et Uli Hebe, man kann dir überall folgen, wo es soziale Netzwerke gibt. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst in der Ligatur. Und dann auch nochmal herzlichen Dank an die vorherigen Gäste, Michael Postel, Marius Seuke und Fabian Pakulat. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 260. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell, rasenfunk.de, supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und auch unsere Gäste profitieren davon. Sie bekommen natürlich ein Gästehonorar. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bleibt den Rasenfunk gewogen und bitte empfehlt uns weiter, vor allem die Ligatour. Danke euch und bis bald, machts gut, ciao!